bookmarks that drown in the pages and a
cake pan that takes the first bite it's
episode 10 of loot
are you a cashier we're just glad to see
me back to bookmarks this one looks like
liquid and this umbrella keeps liquid
off of you and has a porthole designers
at MIT have created wallets that make
money tactile and visceral again they
wirelessly connect to your bank account
and every time a transaction is made
they vibrate as your bank account grows
and shrinks they inflate and deflate and
as you approach a monthly budget you set
an electronic hinge becomes more and
more difficult to open these salad
servers leave a hair in your dish and
why buy a rocking horse when you can
ride a rock and wiener it's not for sale
but you can own a bacon flavored
lollipop these rings look like emoticons
the same company sells a comma pendant
and quotation mark earrings now don't
worry
razor now makes a scooter with a spark
cartridge on the back these kids decided
to ride it through gasoline keep tabs on
what your kids do when you're not around
with this AC adapter hiding a tiny
little secret camera and knowing they're
safe relax on these pillows shaped like
manhole covers fire hydrants and cats
and dogs get it DuckTales mozart
decomposing since 1791 and now when you
undress you dissect a frog layla used
facebook to tell us about napkins with
built-in origami directions camouflage
toilet paper and a chocolate bar
calculator --less ass-crack told me
about a pen so packed full of ink it
lasts seven years and manga monster 32
brought us this awesome lego jewelry now
do you like aerosol cheese we'll try
aerosol pancakes spray it in the pan and
pick one of four flavors pretty kins
recommended Fred Flair where I found
this awesome
ipod hoodie that's it for today but
there's a brand new episode of Vsauce
Leanback coming this week and a big
announcement on Friday so be sure that
you're subscribed to vsauce vsauce too
as always thanks for watching